am i beautiful dan you're supposed to
tell me I'm pretty I woke up this
morning in full midlife crisis mode I'm
not even midlife crisis it's quarter
life but I decided to dye my hair blonde
because I feel like I'm losing control
of so many things I'm like I need
something to take control oh and I
remember seeing the tweet words like if
you see a gay dieter hair they're in
crisis and I was like that's accurate
and that's wonder dye my hair blonde
today one I'm balding which is another
reason why I want to dye my hair blonde
because I'm like I can't do much with my
hair anyway so this is one small thing I
can do when I decided to dye my hair I
posted on Facebook that I was looking
into doing it and one of my great pots
you literally just comment please no and
so that's even more incentive to do it
because like you're not tell me what I
can do with my hair I want to call my
mom and see what she thinks about this
if I get a voicemail house Oh mom this
is hello I call three times so I am
dying my hair blonde today now mom you
did not have to drag me like that we are
recording what if they really like
really artsy and cute then you know we
live and we learned we have to go
through things to find ourselves okay
I'll just kind of let you know I'm going
blonde love you okay so mom's on board
sort of so let's just do it you know
whatever hi my name is huge Ishita
I'm gonna be dyeing client's hair today
I'm hoping just one time speech and just
toner it and comes out pretty blonde I
think his hair it's a little bit close
and I think so the beer is like their
texture is different from what you have
the hair so it's gonna be a little bit
different process and I'm like like over
30 to 40
[Music]
well the first step based on the close
my eyes figures though I'm crossing my
fingers
ready let's do it is it gonna be cold it
would be a little cold okay okay this is
happening
[Music]
dan what is it say would you say I'm
like an old Cisco right okay yes so now
we wait we're doing a Midway checked in
it's a working yay
dan keeps making faces oh is this
showing a blonde you can see it really
Oh
so my beard is one two underneath Wow
could you die your eyelashes I would say
that sounds like a no hahaha I mean it's
yes because it's hair so it's possible
but the fact that it's next to your eyes
probably not smart
[Music]
oh I've no context of what I look like
so this is like you see me I don't know
what I look like right now so we're back
and we're gonna add a little toner hold
on yes so it has little still like
orange so we will try to counter it a
little bit orange corner oh great I feel
like I'm gonna have to like meticulously
plan my outfits around what like a
beanie with like a blue beanie with my
blonde hair oh yeah this is gonna
explain my fashion Wow
so I'm about to look at myself I have
been like maybe an hour and a half that
we've been like messing with my hair and
I have no context of what I look like
other than my top lip grow can barely
see is very blonde I don't know I'm not
nervous I'm excited cuz everyone keeps
saying it looks good I probably will not
recognize myself 3 2 1
holy I love this this beer looks so cool
Wow
I do feel like a Pokemon gym leader
that's exactly what I feel this is cool
I love it too it is so pretty I think
I'm gonna have to get used to seeing
myself in a it's like it's like a shock
it is definitely a shock Wow I want to
FaceTime my mom
hi I will say the lighting makes me look
like an old man I kind of dig it but I
don't hate the blonde it is definitely
different
I I like it no just well good I'm gonna
keep it for at least a week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so you don't think it looks bad
I just wanted to call and show you and
it'll match
[Laughter]
[Music]